floating point is that magical format
we're all kind of familiar with it's
super easy and especially in game
development insanely useful but
simultaneously super difficult and
riddled with foot guns and gotchas why
is it that if you've got two floating
point numbers a and b then if a and b
are different numbers then how is a
minus b equal to zero or if a and b are
both greater than zero why is it that a
plus b can be just equal to a let's dive
in a bit here so starting with the
history back in the early 20th century
actually i'm just going to skip all of
this let's talk about how they work but
before that let's clarify that for the
most part when i say float i'll be
referring to a 32-bit float like in c
plus but everything still holds true for
anything like double precision or
whatever else languages like javascript
for example numbers are all double
precision but that doesn't change what
we're learning here chances are if
you're on a computer and working with
numbers you're either working with
integer values or floating point values
because those are basically the two
types of data that consumer hardware
works with floating point numbers are an
approximation to the set of real numbers
and they pretty much look like this
here's kind of an example of the layout
of a floating point number we're talking
about 32 bits so there's 32 bits here
hopefully if i didn't draw this wrong
and i'll just add some nice colors so
here on the left the blue bit that's the
sign bit that determines if it's
positive or negative
then you've got eight bits of exponent
and finally 23 bits of mantissa or
fraction
a small detail to keep in mind is that
although i've drawn it this way the bit
indices go from 31 to zero the most
significant bit is the sign bit and the
least is on the right so i kind of drew
this backwards
and the way that this is interpreted is
with this equation here
negative 1 to the power of the sine
times 1 dot mantissa times 2 to the
power exponent minus 127 so basically
you have a bit that controls the sign
positive negative you've got this
mantissa which is like a fractional
multiplier and the only unintuitive
detail here is that this one it's
implicit
meaning it's just assumed to be there so
long as whatever is stored in the
exponent is non-zero in other words this
part is all zeros zero zero zero zero
zero and the exponent is just two raised
to the power of the exponent and it's
also offset by 127 so that you can
represent both big and tiny numbers i
get that this probably isn't intuitive
so we'll do a quick example
okay so just to drive it home a bit
let's do a quick non-trivial conversion
to float so here we go we're not going
to do a million of these so i'm just
going to do 250 250.8
for no specific reason other than it's
not super hard so start with the integer
portion it's a simple base 10 to base 2
conversion which is just a series of
divide by twos so 250 divided by 2
equals 125 with a remainder of 0. 125
divided by 2 is 62 remainder 1. i'll
just kind of fast forward through this
that i don't want to narrate this whole
thing
and when you get your answer you just
reverse the bits and that gives you
one one one one zero one zero and now
you have to convert the fractional
portion so that's 0.8 and that's done by
a series of multiplied by twos so 0.8
times 2 is equal to 1.6 so you take the
1. now you got 0.6 times 2 and you get
1.2 you take the 1 again
0.2 times 2 equals 0.4 take the 0
0.4 times 2
get 0.8 take the 0 and you're back at
0.8 so 0.8 times 2 is 1.6 but you're
basically repeating at this point so
full number then is
this long string i'm not going to read
that out the next detail in the note is
that the leading one is implied since
the exponent is non-zero so we just have
to move the decimal place to the right
of the first one and that means you
moved seven decimal places
so it'll be 2 to the power 7. since it's
2 to the power exponent minus 127 you
add 127. so the exponent that you store
is 134 and that's one zero zero zero
zero one one zero not going to bother
showing the math on that so the full
number then is
this thing so you get zero and then one
zero zero zero zero one one zero and
then
and then that whole long string of ones
and zeros
and converting back is the same process
in reverse i'll be a bit lazy and i'll
just take the mantissa convert it back
to decimal that's 804 7821 the mantissa
is 23 bits so 2 to the power 23 is
838608
so divide one by the other and you get
nine three seven and some junk the
exponent is
one zero zero zero zero one one zero or
whatever converted to decimal that's 134
subtract 127 for the offset and that's
seven
and locate the exponent since the
exponent isn't zero the mantissa has an
implied leading one so you get two to
the power seven times
1.9593 whatever
and that's 128 times 1.95
whatever and that gives you
250.8003052 and some crap give or take
and yeah it's not exactly 250.8 and
that's actually perfectly normal and
we'll talk about that in a second so
remember how i said the one is implied
if the exponent is non-zero well the
obvious question then is well what
happens when the exponent is zero
you get what are called subnormal
numbers sometimes also referred to as
denormal numbers and these are kind of
neat they're like a little hack on top
of floating point to get some coverage
on the range between the smallest
normalized numbers and 0. the smallest
possible floating point number where the
exponent isn't zero is pretty easy to
figure out it's just exponent one
mantissa all zeros and this will give
you a number like
1.17549 something e to the negative 38.
the problem is that the range of
floating point numbers kind of abruptly
stops at this min value so you've got
coverage from here to 1
but between here and 0 there's nothing
the subnormal numbers allow us to extend
the range of coverage to that gap around
0. so with this gap you can get some
weird behavior with floating point
calculations like let's say you're
staring at some code that looks like
this if a is not equal to b then return
the inverse
looks pretty straightforward except that
without subnormal numbers subtracting
two unequal but extremely small numbers
could lead to a divide by zero despite
them not being equal if they're both
super small let's say that one is the
smallest normalized number or float min
and the other is the tiniest bit more
then the result of a minus b is smaller
than float min or the smallest
normalized value and without subnormals
well that just gets turned into zero and
you're gonna have a bad time now these
sub normals can be disabled due to
performance concerns so depending on the
compiler and optimization level you
might enable flush to zero which also
means that you could have something work
in debug mode and not in release which
is always so much fun to track down
anyway if a does not equal b but a minus
b equals zero now you know why now that
we've talked about the basic format
let's talk about how floating point
covers the range of real numbers but to
do that we need to talk about integers
first this is just a quick refresher
there's nothing super special we're
touching on
you've got a bunch of bits each
represents a digit and a base two number
so if i've got something like zero zero
zero one one zero well that's two to the
power two plus two to the power one or
six
pretty straightforward the only thing to
specifically call out is that the
integers they exactly cover the space of
possible integer values
let's just talk about positive numbers
so if i've got a four bit integer that
means i can represent anything from zero
zero zero zero to one one one one or in
base ten that's from zero to fifteen and
there's no integer values in that range
that cannot be represented this is
leading to the fact that floating point
numbers they are approximations to the
set of real numbers they do not cover
their space exactly they get as close as
they can your mantissa is how much
precision you get so let's say that
we're looking at the floating point
values 1 and 2 you've got a 23 bit
mantissa so 23 bits gives you 8 million
388 608 possible values which means the
range between 1 and 2 is cut up into
segments of 1 over 8 million or so
and that works out to about
1.19209 e to the negative 7 and we can
confirm this by taking the value of 1 as
a float and incrementing the mantissa by
one bit the smallest possible increment
and the result is 1.000011921
i think the difference being about 1.19
e to the negative seven which is cool so
i'm not crazy and just telling you
random lies and incidentally if you're a
c
programmer this is exactly what float
epsilon is set to if you've ever
wondered why that number was magically
chosen we're about to touch on that the
next interesting thing is that as we get
to the next range of numbers so the
range two to four
that range will also get caught up into
eight million three hundred and eighty
eight thousand six hundred and eight
values
but since the range is now doubled it
should be about 2.38 e to the negative
six for each segment
and when we do the math so we construct
a float value of 2.0 then we increment
the mantissa by one and the difference
is exactly that 2.38 e to the negative
six
what we've been kind of driving at here
is that there's this spacing between
each adjacent float and that spacing
actually has a name it's called an alp
or the unit in the last place
and it's the distance between each
adjacent floating point value
and what's interesting is that spacing
is non-linear the set of floating point
values isn't evenly distributed
as you get closer to zero you get way
more floating point values like in the
example of one to two you got eight
million different floating point values
but it gets halved for every power of
two you go out so the further you go out
the looser the approximation is
and we ran into this exact problem in
the world generation series if you
haven't seen that series i've been
building out a series on building out
entire earth-sized planets in javascript
and 3js
and with a mantissa of 23 bits you get
roughly 7 digits of precision in base
ten give or take i'm just kind of being
hand wavy here but what that means is
that when you've got one really big
number and one really small number like
in the video we talked about being at
one hundred thousand and trying to add
one millimeter or
0.001 then you just get a hundred
thousand because there simply isn't
enough precision to handle that we
talked to the start how if a is greater
than zero and b is greater than zero you
could end up with a plus b is equal to a
and that's why
another interesting property of floating
point numbers since we're talking about
how their approximations to the set of
real numbers
is that for smaller integers
they actually correspond exactly one to
one they exactly cover the set of
integer values up until a certain point
you can see here we can plug in a bunch
of integer values into the float here
let's say i want to represent a thousand
that's easy just turns out as 2 to the
power 9 times 1.95 blah blah blah it's
exactly representable in floating point
and it turns out since you've got 23
bits of precision in the mantissa you
can represent every single integer value
up to 2 to the power 24 which is kind of
neat that gives you up until the integer
value of about 16
777 thousand two sixteen but try adding
just one more to that and you can't
that's the limit and at one six seven
seven two one seven they can't be
represented anymore and floating point
will only cover even numbers and skip
every odd number so floats are fuzzy
representations of real numbers and
because they're not exact the math can
behave a little differently than you
might expect leading to subtle bugs and
errors the classic example thrown around
is 0.1 plus 0.2 does not equal 0.3 which
can throw people off the problem here is
that those numbers may be exact in base
10 but in base 2 they may not be the
first value 0.1 is actually 0.0 and then
0 0 1 1 repeating forever so when you're
looking at say 0.1 plus 0.2 what you're
actually doing is
float of 0.1 plus float of 0.2 all pass
through float again and comparing that
to just float of 0.3
notice the slight difference here you
don't have infinite precision on the
computer
so these small conversion steps can lead
to slightly different results
pretty annoying isn't it and this
actually leads to a more general problem
with floating point numbers
and it's that comparisons between
floating point values are actually error
prone and really tricky to get 100 right
sometimes you'll see someone say
something just like
just add an error tolerance for example
instead of just being a straightforward
a equals equals b type of situation you
might instead do absolute a minus b is
less than epsilon and even c plus
supplies you with this handy epsilon
value you've got float epsilon which a
lot of people use as a sort of error
tolerance check
but from earlier in the video you can
see that this value is actually
calculated as one up or unit in the last
place from 1.0 it's the next adjacent
floating point value to 1.0 so around
that range yeah that value kinda works
but under one this error tolerance is
actually gigantic
and you also know that as floating point
values increase the distance between
adjacent floating point values increases
so after two one alp is 2.38 e to the
negative six two times larger than float
epsilon so after 2 it's not even
possible for two floating point values
to be within float epsilon of each other
making that error tolerance check
completely useless you'd think of
something as simple as comparing two
numbers was going to be straightforward
but unfortunately it isn't or at least
has the potential to be a total
nightmare
at this point there's a whole rabbit
hole to disappear down if you want to
keep exploring the subject i'll have
some links at the end of the video
when you're dealing with floating point
everything kinda sucks i mean things
work most of the time until they subtly
and infuriatingly don't and without a
deep and thorough understanding of the
format and what you're working with you
could end up spending hours or days or
whatever chasing dead ends blindly
adding checks or desperately changing
the doubles and hoping your problems
just kind of magically go away
so
good luck
if you want to keep going down the
rabbit hole though i'd recommend
starting with what every computer
scientist should know about floating
point
and once you've digested that visit
bruce dawson's blog he has a
ridiculously in-depth series on floating
point
i hope that was helpful cheers